بدأ المحرك السري الثاني الآن في
سحب
مضخات توربو الإشعال بالمحرك وصولاً إلى سرعة الطيران ،
ويفصل البرج السري الثاني بين
مضخات المحرك التوربينية بسرعة الرحلة
وإقلاع
الطائرة soyuz ms-20 مع اثنين
من المشاركين اليابانيين في رحلة
الفضاء ورائد الفضاء الذين بدأوا الآن رحلتهم
إلى العالم  محطة الفضاء بعد
30 ثانية من قيام أطقم الرحلة
بالإبلاغ عن أداء جيد في
المرحلة الأولى ، تم تأكيد الفصل في المرحلة الأولى ،
أكملت معززات الحزام الأربعة وظيفتها
140 ثانية
معزز حكيم ثاني
[موسيقى]
والاستعداد لفصل الاتصال
، تم تأكيد إغلاق المرحلة الثالثة وتأكيد فصل المركبة الفضائية
بعد ذلك  ستكون الخطوة هي نشر المصفوفات
الشمسية ويمكنك رؤية تلك المصفوفات الشمسية
تتكشف
الآن وسأخبرك أن هذا هو
MC موسكو وسويوز MS20 الآن في طريقها إلى
محطة الفضاء الدولية
تحمل رائد الفضاء الروسي الكسندر
الباس ومشاركين في رحلة الفضاء اليابانية
يوساكو مايازاوا ويوزو
هارانو على 420. كل  حدث شيء من خلال
الكتاب مع حدوث الإقلاع في الوقت المحدد في الساعة
38 1 و 15 ثانية صباحًا بالتوقيت المركزي 238
و 50